hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up against armor sets out
his mission to make Britain a clean
energy superpower and lead the world on
zero carbon electricity
the government's plans to scrap EU laws
by the end of the year are undemocratic
and risk efforts to address the climate
crisis according to environmental groups
citing new legal research
the landside in Brazil kills more than
40 people with the country's environment
Minister warning climate disasters and
not going away
[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now for Kia stalma says making
Britain a clean energy superpower one of
his five National missions now that's if
labor wins the next election in a major
speech in Manchester he said under a
labor government Britain would lead the
world in making all electricity
production zero carbon by 2030 well
let's get more on this now from our
politics and business correspondent
Amanda acass thanks so much for joining
us Amanda what do you think this says
about Labor and secure stamas
commitments to climate change moving
forward
well I think labor are very keen to
demonstrate that this really is a big
priority for them if they're to win the
next general election this pledge to end
the involvement of any fossil fuels in
an electricity generation in Britain by
um is a clear distinct pledge and it is
very different it stands out from
anything that we have heard from the
government so far on this and in
particular I think it's it's more
distinct than any of the other pledges
that we heard from zakira starma today
particularly in comparison with the five
promises set out by Rishi sunak at the
start of the year now the promise to
turn the UK into a clean energy
superpower isn't new this was a key
promise made by uh secure stama at the
labor Party Conference in the Autumn as
well as the founding of the Great
British energy a new publicly owned
company designed to invest in and really
concentrate on renewable energy sources
clay really I think what we heard from
secure stama was a real determination to
marry together two big priorities
progress towards the country's Net Zero
commitments as well as really
capitalizing on the economic
opportunities of the green Industrial
Revolution Let's have a listen
zero carbon British electricity by 2030.
a huge goal which will allow us to
accelerate to Net Zero
make no mistake this goal would turn
Britain into a clean energy superpower
it will put us ahead of any major
economy in the world that's the shop and
take a breath by the way
now secure did set out some more detail
about how labor would hope to get there
insulating 19 million homes training
more people to be heat pump engineers
and so on and interestingly he also made
reference particularly in the questions
um to the fact that there's big
investment in Green Technology and a big
focus on this from the US government
also in the EU of course concerns that
the UK economy risk being overtaken by
other parts of the world on this now how
does this compare to the current
government policies
um well it's not really quite as
ambitious we know of course the
governments are planning to get to Net
Zero by 2050 and although there are
various grants to try and decarbonize
um uh generation of power nothing as
specific as this 2030 goal we do know of
course early this month the government
set up the new Department of energy
security and Net Zero to be headed by
Grant shapes a bit of return to the old
labor equivalents Departments of energy
and climate change set out by Gordon
Brown back in uh 2008 and this is one of
their priorities to work towards
um uh Net Zero although clearly I think
the government's Focus really at the
moment from everything we've heard is
more about energy security and bringing
the cost of people's bills down and I
think fundamentally unless that
department gets substantial new powers
and new money it's not really clear how
much difference that will really make
but perhaps we might find out more in
the budgets next month okay Amanda thank
you very much mad at acas in Westminster
there
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other stories now and labor says
fishermen in the Northeast have had the
door slammed on them after the
government said it wouldn't be
investigating further into the mass
crustacean die off along the T side
Coast now local fishermen and
environmental campaigners have long
believed that the dumping of material at
Sea from dredging sites could be
responsible though the government
disputes that concerned about the impact
of livelihoods and jobs generational
Pride impacted by the government's
indifference they said the entire
fishing fleet in Hartlepool is finished
There's No Business left they failed us
when we begged them to listen we had a
further review with leading scientific
advisors that came out with the what was
published to the committee into the
house and we understand that this has
been a novel pathogen as the most likely
explanation for what happened in the
Northeast
British power generator Drax group says
its profits Rose by 83 percent to 731
million pounds last year now Drax
generates electricity in North Yorkshire
by burning wood pellets and says its
power plant is crucial to energy
security but critics are slamming the
hundreds of millions in green subsidies
the company receives accusing it of
green washing
now U.S treasury secretary Janet Yellen
says her candidate for the new president
of the World Bank will be committed to
fighting climate change and the World
Bank expects to appoint a new president
by early May and the U.S candidate has
always been selected now Yellen was
speaking at the G20 meeting in India
where climate Finance is expected to be
a key talking point
and 40 people have been killed by a
landslide in Brazil caused by heavy
rains and flooding rescue teams are
still searching for people and assessing
the damage in the Sao Paulo region now
while visiting the area Brazil's
environment and climate change Minister
warned extreme weather events driven by
climate change won't go away
more than 1 800 cities are as vulnerable
as this one this changing in the
temperature the change in the climate
this is not going to change
unfortunately we the government are the
ones who will have to work to adapt
their cities looking to the poorest ones
who live near mountains
now environmental groups say the
government's plans to scrap EU laws by
the end of the year undermined democracy
and could significantly harm efforts to
address the climate crisis citing new
legal analysis they say the plans will
give too much power to ministers they
even threaten Environmental Protections
now the government says the bill is
needed to amend or remove burdesome EU
law will joining me now is lawyer Angus
Eames from environmental law charity
client Earth one of the groups actually
involved in the research Mr Eames thank
you so much for joining us on the daily
climate show if you would to outline for
our viewers if these EU legislations are
scrapped what this will mean for people
in the UK
thanks for having me on
um so this bill would effectively scrap
all laws on our books from the time when
the UK was in the EU
um now those laws are touched on a wide
range of subject areas that affect
people's lives on an everyday basis
There are rules that dictate the quality
of drinking water air quality
food standards protections for species
and habitats but also consumer
protections and employment laws so the
bill would effectively scrap all of
these at the end of this year
and is there any way to delay that
scrapping what would you like to see
moving forward
well we think that the bill for reasons
that pass will come on to should be drop
citizen in its entirety
um it represents a transfer of power of
legislative power from Parliament to the
government who would leave decisions
about the topics I've just talked about
in the hands of ministers with
professori no oversight from Parliament
um we recognize that
laws from the UK's time in the EU might
be up for a review they might be
changing they might be amending to best
Britain now that we left the European
Union and uh we don't object that
process
um we we believe there are lots of laws
that could be improved
um we would say that the process by
which the bill and vision so that is
irresponsible uh and it creates too much
time pressure and a bit of a ticking
time bomb
okay anger seems thank you so much for
your time on the daily climate show
today
okay now just a reminder that you can
watch Tom heat tackle issues around
River pollution and sewage that's on
Saturday and Sunday at 3 30 here on Sky
News
and if you scan the QR code on the
screen right now you can listen to this
week's edition of climate cast and just
subscribe now wherever you get your
podcasts from
and before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you about the environment or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of scan
this QR code on your screen right now
and send us your questions and we'll try
to get to the bottom of them on the
climate Show with Tom Heap
Well for now that's all from us I hope
you've enjoyed the show join us again on
the daily climate show next week at 3
30.
foreign